we were working on the late night show
and you start out to SNL and you were
young yeah yeah I was like 27 or 28
young guy and I that's a I worked there
for years as a writer and I remembered
the pressure and I was thinking about it
today to be a performer and be that
young and the pressure of that live show
and the pressure just constantly week
after week after week how did you learn
to cope with that it's a yeah I have
really bad anxiety when I was on that
show talking about yes I did little
things I tried to do like meditation to
UM I do that was helpful
yeah that's helpful the one guy it was
Jeff Bridges he saw me when I was on the
show I was really nervous and he told me
a story he said you know when I was I
was an Iceman Cometh with Robert Ryan
and every time before every take he
would get nervous and he and I said wow
all these years you still get nervous
and he said yeah I'd be really afraid if
I wasn't afraid and I was like oh that's
interesting and Jeffrey's eggs so yeah
that's that's your buddy man is that bad
bad bad anxiety that's your buddy man
you know put your arm around it and just
get out there I saw him on the red
carpet of the Golden Globes better and I
go hey you know I I told you no I bet
you you telling me that really help me
and and in my time on the show really
did you know just like don't fight that
put your arm around it and hear what you
were talking oh yeah yeah yeah and then
I said he goes we'd you're gonna go out
after the thing tonight and I go no I
got a after I'm at right after the show
ends I'm going to I got to go home cuz I
have a 5:00 a.m. call in Chatsworth
tomorrow I goes no band stay I'll get
drunk that's where the best [ __ ] comes
from was like wait why yeah
let's get drunk and I was like oh that's
what it is yeah I misheard you I
misheard you I'm a dummy